stop the show Gang let's talk about that
middle class famous store baby oh baby
coming up to the fourth quarter on that
down to the Finish Line only a few times
to see us again gang It's a Good Time
come on out and see the live show to mix
a stand-up comedy plus we played a
little late YG with the crowd it's a
great way to introduce new people to the
show so bring the squad with ya uh
Philadelphia sold out you snooze you
lose we got some tickets left for the
second show in Providence Rhode Island
in December and we got some a few
tickies left for our second show in
Boston in December get those hickies
let's party gang this episode is brought
to you by good pals over there to
establish titles with established titles
you can purchase as little as one square
foot of land and you can call yourself a
lord or a lady good Lord that's a lady
it's not only fun but it helps reserve
the Scottish Woodlands over there which
is really nice established titles plants
a tree and works with global Charities
to support Global reforestation
with every order a couple of good peeps
guys title packs give you at least one
square foot of dedicated private land on
an estate in edelston Scotland and you
get the official certificate with a
Crest boom right there we got it on
camera throw it out in your boss's face
yeah hey I ain't working Saturday take
it I'm a lord uh it makes an amazing
last minute gift this average titles is
running a Black Friday sale right now
plus if you use the code garbage you get
an additional 10 off they go go to
establishtitles.com get your gifts now
and help support the channel support the
people who support us baby we love it we
appreciate it and it's not like uh don't
name you it's not like naming a star
after somebody do it right be making a
lord or a lady established titles.com
garbage do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
cam Evan Ryan and H Foley hey everybody
out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage it's our little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it out they're going to be
classy compared to just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at Anthony's basement she's out
doing a smash and grab job over at the
pharmacy good for her so we don't got to
worry about deodorant for a couple of
weeks my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week what
are you gonna do he is the CEO of are
you garbage he is an international
businessman he's the prince of Park
Avenue but always the king of the boards
baby give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
Hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
over a hundred thousand Mexican kids are
doing all right over here then the
greatest uh website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage love
that money check it the [ __ ] out gay yes
sir and how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the man
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones and twos crosses the t's dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dudes
what's up T-Bone oh this is gonna be fun
I'm using a lot of big words so this guy
thinks I'm cool guys got me nervous I'm
not gonna lie I hate that I hate I hate
that people think I'm smart it's the
[ __ ] one come on you think we're
idiots let's be honest it's got a
collared shirt on God damn it they're
[ __ ] worst you I'm from [ __ ]
outside
you do look smart you're you're [ __ ]
just as I ate at [ __ ] Wawa you think
I don't understand the life yesterday
you're wearing pink that's like a
tailored tooth I really [ __ ] up yeah
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
you guys it's a pink shirt you guys see
a tuxedo yeah
we could be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests here with us
today for the first time he is a very
funny very successful stand-up comedian
writer actor producer and director you
might have seen him in but not limited
to Get Him to the Greek Inside Amy
Schumer the female brain Capone opening
act he also directed The Goods totally
awesome Michelle wolf special nice lady
Seth Meyer special Lobby baby he
co-wrote Half Baked wrote 16 episodes at
a Daily Show co-wrote the female brain
he's got two episodes of SNL under his
belt he also executive produced Chris
Rock's tambourine and Total Blackout he
has multiple stand-up specials including
2017's groundbreaking three mics he
co-created the Chappelle show holy [ __ ]
look at that and he has a brand new
special out right now which was released
globally on Netflix that you can watch
as we speak called blocks but the big
question about his mind today is he
garbage not financially I can tell you
that right he's doing all right give him
up for Neil Brennan everybody let's go
hey fellas hey well hey you guys need
money
that's the patreon address again yeah
Patriot that
I can never open
yeah no we yeah we started when we were
before and now it's you know yeah now
but you'll always be poor to people and
it'll always be rich to people because
when they met me they're like this
[ __ ] guy even though they don't know
yeah well you're walking around wearing
pink wearing pink shirts right there
right there what do you got on you like
two three grand what do you carry with I
usually like to carry a lot of cash
go ahead and come rob me
you want to be a hero make a move let's
go I think I'm afraid to get these days
yeah to quote Brian count I'll keep you
busy
that's all right
but uh yeah I don't have like I have
like 50 bucks on me okay that's sad fair
enough I'm no more than no more than 80.
I mean it's like people are weird about
it now it jams you up with the tips and
[ __ ] like that though I got the guys at
the parking garage hate my guts like you
take venmo yeah yeah can we scan yeah
buddy yeah I'm sorry what is the uh give
us the backstory give us the origin
story Neil Brennan lay it on some PA
Roots
[ __ ] guys
for I grew up in born in Philly in Bryn
Mawr Hospital main line and then moved
to Chicago
uh when I was like five then moved back
to Philly when I was 12 till 17. okay
and then jobs or what was a family what
was the yeah I got a new year I was in
the Marine I was 12. and I got four
transfer I got transferred you [ __ ]
jerk off when did two undercover cops
get a podcast look
is it weird not to be wearing Jets
jackets right now
it's gonna be a long hour huh
that you come at me
you take offense you are a Philly
Dirtbag oh really
yeah my dad works don't worry don't
worry about it don't worry about it got
a no-show job uh yeah exactly
um I'm saving this parking spot by the
way
um I got my chair there
yeah my dad got jobs and then um and
then uh
and then and then 17 I came here for
film School my when I was in high school
my brother's comedian Kevin Brennan so I
started like coming up here and hanging
out right uh and then came Boston comedy
yeah Boston Common Club shout out and
then shout out to it and the seller and
The Improv and then was going to NYU in
91 started working the door at the
Boston
only other guys my age were like red
Johnny and the round guy remember them
I've only heard the stories yeah uh John
DiMaggio does a ton of he does the voice
for uh Futurama yeah
wow yeah
holy [ __ ] he's a kill voiceover yeah and
uh great dude
um and and uh Jay Moore and Chappelle we
were the only like young people under
21. so it's pretty crazy
um so me and Dave super close and then
I started getting writing jobs in LA
wrote for singled out one it's on list
unlisted
unlisted all that
on Nickelodeon unlisted Keenan and Kell
[ __ ] uh and then um what age is this
early I looked like 20. yeah it's crazy
so you didn't go to college I went to
NYU for a year you went to NYU for a
year where'd you go to high school down
there Carol you did yeah yeah Bishop
Carroll huh yeah yeah yeah
um and uh you [ __ ] j-o you [ __ ]
jack off how'd you start getting the
writing gigs
I just started tonight well I would give
guys tags at the comedy club like I gave
Dave some jokes here and there and not
even jokes like maybe like a like maybe
a way you could go in that premise or
whatever right and then
um
and then I would tell people I was like
you know you know so then I gotta beef
up the resume yeah and then I was
working for a casting director we at
first singled out all the writers quit
so then they were like you're right come
on that was the pilot that got picked up
and then
nick uh all that shared in office with
singled out so I started talking to this
guy Dan Schneider
who's Google and he's had some yeah
that's it right yep okay all right
moving on yep uh and um I've never heard
that name casually drop in conversation
like oh that one all right yep and uh
and and so submitted to all that didn't
get the job they ended up stealing an
idea from me I didn't know that then
they hired me for the second season that
Pier escargo thing that Keenan and about
I pitched it they didn't hire me used it
then I was like what they hired me the
next season and uh you didn't know
you're on the right path yeah keep your
mouth shut uh yeah exactly uh I just
dropped dime
30 years later I just cried I just
crossed the street I'm ready to come
inside guys uh kids wearing a wire over
here I want that life right behind me
and uh and then
and then like wrote a movie script not
good but I was kind of just kind of had
a spirit to it
pretty met with the producer uh uh then
like a week later Dave met with the same
producer and they were like hey you got
any ideas and he's like yeah I'm uh I'm
me and a buddy of mine are writing a
weed movie now meanwhile we'd never
discuss that uh and they go who and he's
like you've never heard of them trust me
no have you ever seen all that tell us
who I think he goes Neil Brennan and
they're like Neil was just here we love
you so then we pitched the movie we
pitched Half Baked right 30 days later
but we'd never he we went to train
spotting the movie and then he was like
you get to weed one of those it was like
yeah just like why I didn't it wasn't
like you cranked this out a couple of
weeks yeah yeah you got a typewriter
right oh yeah [ __ ] get on there he
didn't he wasn't even like you he's like
a person could do a weaver turn that
yeah and then hand you a bag of heroin
no yeah like all right uh so so then we
we had 30 days to pitch it we had 30
days to get it together and then we took
like 29
the night before crying cranked it out
and it ended up being a lot of the movie
that's it's got some flaws uh but uh the
first movie is when a VHS that me and my
boys would be like probably yeah there's
like sequences in it that are really
funny like that's what that's great like
like there's [ __ ] in it that you go oh
they would do so then it didn't do good
me they've kind of like like stopped
[ __ ] with each other a little bit and
then I was writing movies with this guy
Mike sure who's gone on to do a bunch of
great [ __ ] and then Dave was like we
should do a uh he want to do Playboy
after dark
that Hugh Hefner show there's a much
funnier version of this monologue on the
uh Dave Chappelle Mark Twain Prize okay
I've seen yeah yeah yeah
um and uh so then we did we did a
ditchbell show
uh did good and then we um I guess the
other cops are here guys yeah see what
that is that is this the all that police
Stan Snyder
um so um
so then did travel show he leaves I'm
like what the [ __ ] am I gonna do and I
just was like I'll just let me just do
stand up because it's like I've always
been flirting with it for a while I was
like I was around it and then
and then for the last 15 years so that's
what you've been doing yeah quite the
[ __ ] resume you know like I still
will direct people's specials yeah I
like how you do it I'll still direct
Chris Rock's back well Chris I didn't
bother I Bo Burnham directed but I
produced whatever like I was involved uh
Michelle's Seth's Al Madrigal a couple
of so like crazy people I like because
it's not I don't like
uh doing [ __ ] that takes a long time
because I made this movie called the
goods and it was like it takes a [ __ ]
year yeah and then it and then start to
finish it's a dud and you're like wow
that was a [ __ ] 24 months why
although I did see that in theaters as
well yeah yeah it's a funny movie but
it's like just Disney it was a dud so uh
so now I just like doing [ __ ] that's
shorter and [ __ ] that I can absolutely
control like that's what I like about
these stand-up specials is like it just
you may you can Tinker you can fix it
you can rewrite you can like you can
make I did a reshoot on the new one like
I just you can do you can keep improving
it and I do commercials so it's like
that's super short term there you go
yeah take me back to uh all figured out
taking back to high school going to
Carol what'd you guys live in do you
guys live in a single family home was it
an apartment no you have a single family
home single family home in Philadelphia
yeah what's your pop do he was a tax
lawyer okay I was gonna say he got a
little cash out the billion I got down
here Main Line yeah yeah that's pretty
good but we had also had 10 kids so like
even if you got a child this guy had a
dick habit he can't believe what the
[ __ ] I mean this guy loved [ __ ]
hey who don't I can't blame that guy I
mean you want to pull out everything
garbage pull out game how separated is
everybody how this one is uh 16 years
older than me the oats okay so anyway
kids in 16 years so what the [ __ ] when I
was you know you're a freshman in high
school who who's who's around you and
okay
Nora uh-huh
Peter a little bit
and everybody else is gone Danny's at
Fordham
nor is it University of Illinois man you
are as Irish Catholic as well I can't
believe if it wasn't in the Bible we
don't want it
um Joey Kevin Tommy Mary no Dylan's or
Spencers tell you that right now [ __ ]
play polo We're not gonna [ __ ] name
uh Mary and Peter Nora Danny may they
don't still live there now right someone
do my mom just sold the house like a
month ago what was it was what was the
name of that street that you guys grew
up on uh Parks run Lane
that's classy yeah yeah you guys have a
garage
yeah we didn't use it though there's it
attached or uh detached because on the
main line they can be detached attack it
wasn't you had to there was an outside
it was a corridor to get there yeah
that's pretty close that's pretty cool
is nice you guys you couldn't park your
car in there we I think we would every
once in a while we didn't though what
was the family whip what were you guys
cruising around then we had a uh we had
a Colony Park station wagon the one with
the wood panels
throw you in the back you in the back I
mean giving the finger to the truck
drivers behind you yeah uh and we had
then when I think we got a
white not Bronco but one of them like
SUV type things pretty good yeah what
was the uh did you guys have a fridge in
the garage you have a second fridge out
there we had a freezer
somewhere we had a freezer in the
basement ice pops
no look there was that [ __ ] was
Contraband there was no really she ran a
tight ship like that there was no we
would get dessert we had to sneak candy
in we couldn't have candy in the house
there's a part of the new show where I
go over my mom's rules
like the rules of the house what about
Halloween
yeah there was like a special
dispensation you were allowed to get as
much you could I don't know what
dispensation means
uh look the other way yeah uh you that
was like legally that was legally gotten
but you couldn't have we'd have to sneak
candy in was it like a dental thing or
sugar it was just a show it was like a I
think it was partially like Joy
my parents were born in 1930 and 1933.
thanks my dad was one of 13. holy [ __ ]
how old was he when you were born 43.
damn that's an older yeah yeah church
every Sunday [ __ ] yeah yeah it's a boy
altar boy yeah I did that too you do
good on the weddings and stuff like that
though look at that taste look at a
little taste your beak a little bit Yeah
catch a high profile funeral you'd be a
nice funeral yes local businessman goes
down a bit crime of his life family
shocked they what he they don't know
what it is they don't know what to pay
in altar boy they accidentally give you
a Hyundai yeah a couple undies coming
your way he was in charge yeah let's go
uh who was making the lunches for you in
school in the show Frozen we'd make them
on the weekend what make the sandwiches
on there's at one point there's
literally eight of us that's all so cool
every day yeah yeah Frozen Frozen
sandwiches stacked up in the freezer
take one
stick in your bag
now it's like a 7-Eleven not even
7-Eleven they thought how this is going
yeah they don't always throw them out
especially in those cold winter months
out there on the main line Billy Billy
January you got a cold BB and Jade yeah
you think yeah and then we would eat
around the edges of the sandwich like
rats
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] dude yeah huh so it's not
garbage it ain't classic garbage that's
what I'm saying it's not like oh you
were in the lap of luxury ah started a
caddying when I was 11. what course
in Chicago it was Indian Hill where the
Murray's caddy caddyshacks based on that
sure okay and then in Philly it was
based it was a place called Saint
David's okay Saint David's yeah it's in
Radner okay I did five Valley Forge
Military Academy yeah I did uh we I used
to Candy at the Philmont Country Club a
couple of times sure what it didn't work
one for you no no the hills killed me
yeah I did it over at the at the the
Jewish Club where I grew up in Bluebell
and it was [ __ ] brutal the Jews yeah
yeah
no kidding Kanye
I didn't mean it like that well it's
well it came off
the family program Jesus Christ it is
funny where they get in Philly they're
still like yeah they got a Jewish guy I
remember hearing a Jewish yeah there was
a Jewish club and there was a lot of
people's issue with juice I just don't
sure I'm like what do you yeah
I mean please uh some of the best people
I know uh
unless they tell you
but here's the thing they always tell
you don't they yeah
they do make it known all right this
guy's speaking my language now all right
bro
all right so you caddied
frozen sandwiches what was your mom's
best dish what would she throw at you
for beef stroganoff next question
my mom is great cook yeah if she'd heat
the plates up what wait so whoa yeah on
their own or with the food on it we made
my dad put it beat it into her you beat
the plates up on her own yeah she would
put him in the put them in the oven for
10 minutes before dinner whoa that's
pretty classy
it is weirdly there's something they're
both Irish so it's like some Irish folky
[ __ ] sure you know what I mean like a
thatched roof and a fire going yeah
stove warm and fuzzy a little bit so far
did you guys have a fireplace
yeah we had like a wood yeah there was
like a fireplace nice all right okay
let's talk about kamakoto oh yes talk
about Japanese steel let's talk about
cutting through I got my blade on me
right now oh gang no matter how tough
your Thanksgiving turkey is you can cut
through it like a Samurai with the best
Japanese I don't think you're allowed to
do that the best Japanese steel knives
on the planet with kamakoto baby
kamakoto Builds on over 800 years of
Japanese expertise in creating steel to
make knives that have been meticulously
hand crafted using techniques that date
back to Japan's Edo period they know
what they're doing they got to go they
got the single bevel Edge uh can achieve
an unbelievably sharp edge you can't you
just can't get with other knives you cut
through your rib eye like melted butter
baby like it shroom they were nice
enough they sent me a case what I
haven't told you comes in a nice wooden
case click it open oh really yeah nice
nice uh felt in there ship the promo
code the one knife is proper a heavy
Pike dude this thing means business
actually coming to the studio not your
private room it's used by Michelin star
chefs worldwide every knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee each knife comes from
a gorgeous comes in a gorgeous heavy
duty Ashwood box like I said so so
gifting a Setter 2 is a no-brainer
kamikoto has several special offers
going on right now and is offering our
viewers an extra fifty dollars off any
purchase that's the turkey right there
with discount code garbage just go to
comicodo.com garbage that's km
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com garbage use promo
code garbage for fifty dollars off the
best Japanese the best Japanese steel
knives on the planet do it Kim how about
that butcher box baby I'll love that
butcher box I got three words for you
Deals Deals Deals baby that's four words
but who's counting Black Friday is
coming up it is upon us everybody's
looking for deals on this on that what
about a nice deal on some top Quality
Meat love it grass-fed grass finish wild
caught free range we got it all gang do
yourself a favor and don't miss it on
the Black Friday deals over there
butcher box yeah guys you got uh just
what you want delivered right to your
doorship free shipping for the
continental US no surprise fees you
choose from a variety of box plan
options you can uh from curated to
customize you can change your plan
whenever you want I let them do it let
them they know what they're doing they
know what's moving they know they they
got your best interest at heart with
good meat stadio uh they have exclusive
uh member deals so you can save big on
your favorite Cuts enjoy your a range of
high quality cuts that are hard to come
by at the grocery store at an amazing
value they got recipes they got guys
they got tips like we've said a million
times they sent it to us I got I I got
ground beef I got bacon I got everything
coming on my ears though uh this Black
Friday butcher box is offering our
listeners one of their best steak deals
get two 10 ounce Ribeyes free in every
box for a whole year wait what yeah all
right it's Black Friday put your boxes
offering our listeners one of their best
steak deals get two 10 ounce Ribeyes
free in every box for a whole year when
you join plus an additional ten dollars
off I gotta talk to Johnny butcherbox
signup today at butcherbox.com
aygus code ayg that's free Ribeyes for a
year plus 10 bucks off at butcherbox.com
ayg with Cody what'd you do it that's
pretty good what was the name of the
grocery store that you guys went to
[ __ ] Acme shout out to the ACT what
are we talking about goddamn gentlemen
what are we talking about that's what I
like dude my mom still shops at the Acme
why wouldn't she so does mine where's
she gonna go shout out to Whole Foods
please yeah no my mom
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh did you have a swing set in the yard
growing up no we used to play regular in
the woods Sports because there were a
lot there were six there were six boys
in the face I'm starting right there
yeah basketball Net basketball net a lot
of sports we would call each other the f
word so much it sounded like a hate
crime yeah yeah in the 80s
two years ago it was still a little
rough around the edges silly now ain't
great either yeah Philly this afternoon
let's be honest
a real like yeah that was our solution
everyone was yeah was that yay of course
100 that's what we did 100 we didn't
even know about Gabe it had nothing to
do with gay people oh no it was just uh
and you knew it as an insult is this a
pejorative thing uh the basketball net
was it pejorative Mark that's for you
why you want to Google that real quick
yes do I have the permission to yeah I
got two homework you can use my
dictionary.com account I like it this
guy's got a Primo member
um
did you guys have a set of encyclopedias
at the house growing up
not that I remember were there any
pictures on the wall of the Pope Jack
Kennedy or anybody like that
there's a lot of pictures of there I
think they're running extra hope and of
course let the pope Lenny died
uh there were a lot of pictures of
there was a pope when he came to Chicago
in 81.
Pope John Paul yeah old school second
back to the basketball that was it we
called him Deuce yeah
the basketball net was in ground report
above your sermon
you're in real trouble
uh the basketball that was a portable or
in ground in ground
classic so right there
septic we weren't on sewers whoa yeah
those are those are older houses out
there yeah so septic tanks so we had a
river of [ __ ] water it went running
underneath the in-ground hoop so it's a
mixed well they kept us hungry you know
what I mean yeah now in the I assumed
the best one that was in the driveway
yeah did you have a line marked for
where like the foul shot was please what
are we okay just ask him did you guys
keep the butter on the counter in the
fridge
French keep it in the fridge Irish Mom
I'm surprised with that where'd you keep
the ketchup you just lost a lot of money
Vegas just went belly up Toby call
sandal tell him I'm good for it
what was the next question
uh any pets growing up no no no pets
nothing nothing fish tanks that's a lot
it was yeah it was a Loveless house
Irish Catholic
story this is worse than garbage
what's below garbage
that's again I don't know we don't need
to categorize this let me just tell you
a septic tank so we go to someone was
giving their dog up a local family and
we'd had a dog at one point and we go to
look at I guess I was too young to
remember this but they go look at the
dog and they're doing they're like hey
and then uh one of my sisters goes hey
Mom do you think Daddy will kick this
dog down the steps like he did chipper
chipper didn't long story short didn't
get the dog yeah I'm glad for that dog's
benefit they pulled out last minute jeez
so yeah like a weird
yeah I don't know what you call it I I
feel like I've hit uh
Jesus we should probably stop tape on
this one
you got to go she's going out on patreon
by the way
you're gonna have to see a therapist
poor chipper wherever you are buddy
let's do it all right uh what about the
vacations where would you guys go we did
once they started shedding people some
of the kids it sure got tighter yeah
once the crew got tighter uh they we
went to
Epcot one year all right okay I got to
bring a friend that's what you're the
youngest so that's what I'm saying like
it's a big bag yeah that's not bad uh we
went to uh Hilton Head okay sometimes my
brother was a caddy on the PGA tour
there you go so we'd go to the golf
tournament down there make a week out of
it there you go uh and then uh but
there'd be nine you know still Busch
Gardens or uh no Williamsburg Virginia
no no we went to Williamsburg for a
family reunion
and I believe he plays in the 1700s
brother this is Uncle Blackman my either
I punched my brother or he punched me
one of the other very tense nothing like
a fight on a family vacation on a golf
course
you're fighting on the golf course yeah
you got to fight with the caddy brother
you're pushing fuzzy Zeller out of the
way yeah use it
you've never fought on a golf course you
[ __ ] he's never been thrown out of a
PGA event what do you want [ __ ] it's
funny cattying at that the Philmont
Country Club it was like a celebrity
event and Chris Carter the wide receiver
was in our group and me and my cousin
were doing it we were fighting over the
one bag we got into a fist fight on like
the ninth day Chris Carter had to break
it up did he really yeah the caddies
were fighting yeah we were fighting me
and my cousin over over who gets to
carry Chris Carter's back we were
basically splitting the third bag and it
was like all right you carry it now you
carry it now and they were huge it was
like something had a Caddyshack yeah and
we were like 14 years old we were just
bitching at each other and it was 100
degrees we were walking up and down
these Hills and you know one thing led
to another one thing led to another yeah
yeah all right great real fast I've been
one year old Bobby moynihan's been up
here yeah so it's great to see the game
he gained 400.
he landed on his feet at my lowest in
New York City
um I was walking to do like an open mic
in the East Village like maybe like
seven years ago and people won't always
say oh but you look at Bobby Moynihan
look at Bobby Moynihan and [ __ ]
people walk by me and the guy's like oh
wow what's up Bobby Moynihan and I used
to drive me crazy when I was in such a
bad mood and just in such a low place I
just turned around I was like hey thanks
man good to see you tune in this
Saturday
thanks buddy yeah appreciate it good
stuff all right
um mayonnaise in the house growing up
yeah Miracle Whip helmets helmets okay
all right uh milk with dinner growing up
had to yeah yeah a lot of milk whole
uh I can't see you as a skim family no
that may be your family you're thinking
of look
um enough Badger how many how many I get
I made a career we were all heavy cream
yeah go ahead uh
uh the yeah we had there was no Jude we
couldn't eat drink juice at restaurants
did you guys have that why when you go
to IHOP or whatever well that's not
really a restaurant but yeah all right
so yeah you're right it's a lifestyle
[ __ ]
we went out to eat there was no uh shoes
off at the McDonald's yeah who was
getting married
um so we yeah we had to drink juice
before
we had to like pre-game why is that
juice is too expensive yeah too
expensive okay also think about to do 10
fresh squeezers no you're gonna put a
lot of [ __ ] you're out of the house
enough yeah I know they're 80 bucks in
Drinks Alone stop one soda after if you
went out to dinner once so so what does
this no no soda they're doing no soda
they're doing juice in-house there's no
way they're doing house they're doing
shots of juice in the station wagon how
much of that has translated over into
your adult life like do you mess with
candy
have a program that I'm running right
now okay I eat sugar once a week because
I was eating ice cream every night after
dinner and it wasn't making me fat it
was just gross it was just gr what it
was doing in my like blood sugar I was
like this can't be good so I I feel like
the best way to do it is have a cheat
day but it's sometimes Sunday sometimes
Tuesday I eat dessert all day
yeah like French toast but French toast
is dessert sure so trust me the way I
make it I mean if you're doing it right
uh so I do have a I have weird
discipline things okay like I talk about
in the show blocks on Netflix where like
at one point I was wearing a watch on
stage that would shock me so I would
smile more to remind me to smile more
it's a longer story but yeah it's like
I'm not that sums it up for me very like
disciplined about it's like OCD or
something it's not I just know that like
if I have a Blocker on my phone for
certain [ __ ] like okay I will indulge
myself
until like
to wait past it like I'll just be on the
internet for 17 hours unless you
distance unless I disappoint myself so
that's good how are you how are you with
booze and stuff I I barely drink I just
don't like booze like it doesn't the way
me I don't like the way it makes me feel
like they don't make me feel bad but
it's not better it's not yeah it's not
it's not yeah it doesn't I'm not I know
people that like are euphoric from it
I'm just never you for it from it okay
all right oh man dog collar shocking
themselves special episode are you a
psychopath yeah that's good do you have
human emotion
I gotta say you're the most Charming
robot they really make them look real
now they're pretty lifelike yeah give
them a whole backstory and everything
the nine brothers and sisters holy [ __ ]
what about pizza do you guys have a
favorite pizza spot that you only in the
basement once a month
we do frozen so we wouldn't rarely what
brand we talking this is big I want to
say toastino's is that a thing okay
toastino's pizza rolls yeah Totino's
also they're also in the frozen pizza
maybe Tombstone Tombstone yeah they were
they were big back in the 80s and 90s
what about Elios any stranger to the
Elio's Pizza don't know it what is that
Philly but it's this guy might be
working Deep Cover Philly kid doesn't
know about Helios this guy's a Russian
Jersey where are you from Sicklerville
that Cherry Hill you [ __ ] nothing on
that it looks familiar
also you said when dude you saying when
did two undercover cops get a podcast is
a home run yeah it's all right huh let's
talk about now a little bit all right
um do you want to talks
yeah I got a tux
in all right but here's some Dirtbag
[ __ ]
gotta Tux in 2004 pull out his wallet
[Laughter]
[Music]
mine does the same thing it's like I
don't know what happened I use my shirt
though using a classy handkerchief
that's clear that goes in the classic
you used to blow their nose oh the
pocket yeah wipe my face with it damn
right with a clean corner yeah yeah they
hit me with a root beer barrel keep it
moving
gotten tucks in 2004 or
it's coming back to me now I got it at
the Armani Outlet Jersey in Jersey
that's where the Armani outlet should be
in New Jersey and then held it
and then wore it again
they wanted Chappelle to do best sketch
show at the Emmys I got it for the Emmys
in o4 uh and then and then uh I got shut
out if you're wondering I went home and
went went home empty
um and then uh uh the and then they were
they wanted Dave to do best SketchUp so
he was like come do it with me so I wore
talks got more like fitted modern but
somebody said I look like a uh Bellman
you wore an outlet tux to the Emmys
twice that's all right over 15 years
what about suits what's the suit
situation I got a couple suits I just
picked up a couple in Thailand like
three or four years ago really that's
why everybody real cheap but that's
that's the go-to thing everybody gets
them custom made out there for like two
three hundred bucks yeah and I got
another one did it you did it already
did it I got another free one
John Legend had wears a lot of uh
some label it's a guy's name Paul Smith
and so they did some dinner honoring
John
and then they John made a guest list and
all of us got free suits afterwards or
to wear to the thing where really yeah
oh to go and I'm such a dirt bike I had
to go like so I'm not gonna have to pay
for this I don't have to pay taxes on
this or nothing no yeah this isn't a
gift technically I I this is a name good
story uh about cheapness
um so if you're a Nike athlete you get a
hundred thousand dollars a year in free
[ __ ] yeah my cousin was one yeah yeah so
what did he play soccer yeah so
they uh so like Blake Irvin's a buddy of
mine basketball player and um it's up
late he uh he's very funny dude shot him
on uh text him right now uh and um
he so he would he gives it to me right
he'll give me he'll give me like hey go
run around uh you're gonna wear his
sizes though
[Laughter]
giant blankets uh warm-ups
um the uh anyway so I was I did a
commercial with Giannis antetokupo
recently and I was asking him about it
and he goes I don't use it because they
tax you on it oh yeah
that guy's a real I like it nice and
tight that kid keeps it yeah spend the
hundred grand because they'll tax you on
the 100 Grand he moved the Gatorade
bottle out of the way in an interview
one time because he wasn't sponsored
about him he was like nope yep
at one time flu goes are they paying or
they paying are they paying everything
fantastic
when Jordan put the American flag around
the he the the 92 dream team had the
Reebok logo
um because he's an animal
yeah I heard he used to wear a bracelet
to shock himself so we knew when to
smile Dory he's not he he's not that
hard I already gave myself the flu
let's talk about Thailand uh well
traveled this guy real freak let's go
let's cut this [ __ ] and talk about time
one of those dudes huh
I got two words for you [ __ ] let's go
um how well traveled are you
but I'm uh I've gone to a bunch of
Europe and a bunch of Asia bunch of
Europe is that for work or for like
on a vacation Christmas I'm gonna go to
Thailand and I'm gonna do a show in
Bangkok nice and Chiang Mai I've done
shows in Singapore Tokyo Hong Kong it's
so fun dude yeah because they can't
believe you're there yeah and you don't
have to do like my act's like fine right
now because I just released something so
it's like it'll be decent in well it's
also uh it's like you land in that
country you were just by default the
funniest guy in the country you know
what I mean it's just yeah you could be
like an open Miker here and go to yeah
wherever and it's like oh yeah
did you have you seen this guy and he's
like fine yeah
um he has like two good jokes uh so I go
I do shows and then walk around nice
attack's right off that way too yeah no
you're right your dog god damn right it
is yeah talking about ladder baby love
that ladder yeah we love that ladder
gangs a lot of things in life that you
don't feel like doing me cleaning my
room making my bed brushing my teeth
some things you can put off some things
you can't lift up in the morning
some days you just want to stay in bed
oh for two weeks but gang term life
insurance is something you can't push
off do yourself a favor take care of
your family take care of your loved ones
get yourself a little term life over
there at ladder it'll straighten you out
no needles no doctors it's a good time
yeah guys it's 100 digital when you
apply for three minute coverage or less
just a few questions about your health
and an application uh you need a few
minutes and a phone or a laptop to apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you choose and find out if
you're instantly approved no hidden fees
you can cancel any time get a full
refund if you change your mind in the
first 30 days finally since life
insurance costs more as you age now is
the time to cross it off for your lift
set it and forget it is what I say so go
to ladderlife.com today to see if you're
instantly approved that's latter
l-a-d-d-r-l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage one more time
ladderlife.com garbage do it yeah okay
let's talk about established titles baby
good Lord good lady let's be neighbors
absolutely gang do yourself a favor get
over to established titles purchase a
little piece of the Scottish Woodlands
over there and refer to yourself as a
little Scottish guys title packs give
you at least one square foot of
dedicated land on private estate in
edelston Scotland hello that's an
opinion it's an official certificate
with a Crest boom you got it right there
I got it in my hand
baby I took out a second mortgage on his
thing playing it all on black the first
two people purchased a title pack with
our link will effectively be next to our
plots when a few walking distance a few
minutes walking distance stay off my
lawn let's build the kingdom of garbage
baby yeah you know what I mean uh it
makes a great last minute gift for your
loved ones and we're coming up on gift
giving season baby true they even have a
couple's packs that come with adjoining
plots of land for his and hers his and
his or hers and hers if you catch my
drift officially either way I'm in
officially that lady and Lady officially
change your name to Lord or lady you can
use that name on your credit card plane
tickets add some class to your dating
profile get your little wee-wee wet it
makes an amazing last minute gift a
Savage titles is running a Black Friday
sale plus if you use the code garbage
you get an additional 10 off go to
Savage titles.com get your gifts now
help support the channel do it are we uh
he's playing first class got it we're
flying business business first class is
not really any better on those long
flights I just need a lay flat bed
telling you put on 300 pounds is it
difference believe me no no thanks I'll
take your word for it thumbsy
look I appreciate the offer I have I
have a shock around me to make sure when
I eat yeah this is what happens when
you're allowed to drink juice at the
IHOP yeah this is yeah this is the you
get both those jokes are better than any
of us gave incredible they were kind of
T-Bone added in posts
um yeah no that makes sense business
class business class but I really have a
little bit more space I like points I
like to fly with American American I
made executive Platinum again this year
you're welcome there you go goddamn
Patriot over here I'm uh I'm also
there's a thing called concierge key
that it's like they don't talk about it
it's a wink wink nudge nudge situation
they gotta invite you there's no is that
just with American yeah qualifications
kind of vague
I made it one year really and then and
then that's not like 500 000 miles or
something you gotta fly I don't know I I
don't know it's that vague because I've
flown two I've done on 28 Americans this
year
American flights so
damn I don't I mean I'll probably I I
feel like I'm gonna make concierge you
flew American out here from the coast
right you're from yeah I was in Austin
yeah you're not you were not you live in
L.A yeah live in L.A okay all right
everyone uh ever won a fedora no you
know but I'll I look decent in them
really but I don't wear them
for you
because I don't want you guys to have to
look at a guy in a fedora gotcha but I
look cute I look like surprisingly like
it wouldn't be but it's just awful how
about a kangal you ever sport again I'm
pretty light on the on the I've never
really done a black scent okay I've
never done like a tangle which
[Laughter]
but uh
your heart
um uh yeah I've never really done much
of a black scent never wore a kangal
never wrapped never freestyle rap never
won there was never like a never ever
ever
thinking about it Chappelle Show 2004
you're a young guy so you were in the
what about like Ed Hardy or were you
wearing Ed Hardy shirts and I would have
had like a pant leg up yes a visor on
upside down
like that but it was more of like the
Supreme skateboard all right I would
have been riding an ATV through New York
Riders dear Rough Riders just videos of
you riding doing stunts in your backyard
BMX is right you down Broadway video
yeah he's on love kicking it what now so
no Ed Hardy okay no Ed Hardy now it's
pretty good was there a first
um because even though your dad was a
lawyer you had a lot of kids it's humble
beginnings to a degree humble and it's
like both the same thing but what was
there when you got like your first big
check for whatever that was was there
um an irresponsible purchase
did you buy anything stupid you got a
jet ski
I bought an apartment and I bought a big
ass big screen really and I had a
massage chair which they somebody got me
which a Sharper Image I mean it was
pretty great where'd you buy the
apartment in New York yeah where
58th and 6th and I'm one and I lost
money on it really that's right yeah
it's right there crazy lost money how
many bedrooms
two two bedrooms you were living in that
and why why the Chappelle show was going
on I bought it after the second season
young kid New York City 30 living in
Manhattan yeah killing it that's all
right brushing ass
were you crushing ass
that's what I like to hear peace is upon
you must have been getting a real piece
that's that's pretty responsible though
yeah I brought an apartment and a big
ass oh I got a car I got a like a Lexus
so looking back okay I mean but yeah
yeah you know they have rims on it
come on now now no Rams
what color was it
purple canary yellow no I'm kidding it
was uh no it was black it was it was
Costa I mean it was like you know off
the rack cocaine white [ __ ]
uh yeah no it was nothing wild what are
you driving in nowadays what do you whip
right now I got that Tesla
I got that Tesla cause uh you guys know
how I don't experience human emotions
right sure right so anyway you wanna
have someone to talk to so we have the
same charging so yeah like me and the
robot hit it off
uh I got a uh I test drove it I had like
a I had uh I had a I had a Prius and
then I had the Chevy bolt or the Vault
you're a real understated guy I try to
be I mean you're rocking a Prius I yeah
and then and then I respect that and
then I I don't know
I test drove a Tesla have you guys
driven one I've been in the back I got
an Uber it was so [ __ ] I hit the gas
pedal and laughed out loud and I was
like I have to get like nothing makes me
laugh out loud so I got one and uh I got
you a couple times on this episode I
just want to point that out look and I'm
gonna buy you it just needs to be
rebooted how much what's your price
um I'll let them go for 15 000.
it's like a horse it's real expensive to
feed them you know what I mean
it's easy
it's the ink that's where they get yeah
uh so I got a Tesla okay and uh but and
I had a Rolex
and even though you didn't ask no but I
didn't I was like what am I getting at
I made someone get it for me okay on a
job
you put that in like your writer or
whatever it was I wrote for Ellen's last
eight Netflix Ellen DeGeneres last
Netflix okay I never said anything about
money and then our age was like what
what money you want I was like just give
me a Rolex that [ __ ] is big in the Rolex
game okay I didn't wanna really I wanted
Ellen's [ __ ]
she's like sharp huh she's sharp as [ __ ]
and funny as [ __ ] you let them pick it
out just give me just give me something
it's a longer story but yeah
um but uh yeah she's funny as [ __ ] and
like of course constantly flipping
[ __ ] out
constantly flipping real estate smart
like she likes the action are you doing
any of that you got any investment
properties floating around I have an nft
I put it all in crypto bro uh no I put
none of it what'd you do with the Rolex
you sold it got rid of it yeah I just
sold it really yeah because they
appreciate no I know
you took a gift
that's not a gift yeah but it was the
payment yeah it's like yeah but that's
how like did you make money off of the
deal yeah what how much was the watch
work not how much but you made more than
what they bought the watch for you yeah
for sure does it say like two Neil love
Ellen or anything it says the name of
the special relatable if you're out
there and you have the relationship
I'll buy it and put it on set that's
pretty good goddamn rich person joke of
like Rolex relatable wink get it it's
not relatable you poor [ __ ]
that's like Jon voigt's LeBaron I like
that what is your friends from Seinfeld
oh he ever heard of it
um George was driving around in the car
oh that's really yeah but it was the uh
periodontist John Voight not the actor
that's very funny every time I watch
very little Seinfeld whenever I hear
about I'm like very funny yeah he knows
what they know what they were doing
those two you got a pool out at the
house I just got a pool you put a pool
in no I I moved yeah oh yeah nice never
had a pool sold the old place
nope
guys
I hate to have to go public with any of
this
well you worked hard what are you
talking about people
nobody thinks that worked hard that's
crazy
no but first of all nobody thinks it
worked out uh
I'm doing all right doing all right of
course yeah jacuzzi in the pool
yeah right on the side of it no but by
the way it's not a big pool but we have
Rich guys 10 ground right yeah okay
[Laughter]
is it salt water or regular regular and
do you walk in or is it stepped do you
have like the Beach entry steps I don't
like the Beach entry do you have any
kind of filtration system in the house
with the water like soft water I have
like that I have a Berkey a Berkey which
is like that's reverse osmosis right no
it's like it's a it's like a thing it's
like a crap okay it's like a silver
thing oh does it have like the spring on
the top you take it off and then you
have to put my wife has it yeah it does
some chemists some problems you don't
got it no my wife does are you not
married anymore uh no I am married why
it's a Poland Spring man yeah I got the
five gallon jug that was uh I got like
the I do you got like the that one yeah
well now they go in from the bottom but
yeah do they run a lot of Technology
over there wait what you open it at the
bottom it slides in you put the thing on
oh wow like it's not like a used car
dealership right good for them yeah an
Australian I do I do use the cone cups
though just like three ounces yeah
you got two sinks in the bathroom
you know what I have though to speak to
my electric shock you know the airport
thing where it's the sensor you got a
sensor in your bathroom yeah the soap
too no just the the just the water oh
really I don't waste it holy [ __ ] yeah
that's like a fancy restaurant no it's
their event they're on Amazon you can
that's the thing is you just want you
got I want one of those you go on Amazon
they're like not expensive I just got a
pizza cutter like for the first time
like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] King of
England yeah I just it was like that's
what for rich people and I looked up on
the crown and you're like what the hell
that
is Bridge know what they're doing let's
go [ __ ] hey they deserve to be in
charge been cutting this pizza with a
spoon my whole life uh what's that in
the shower rainfall what do we got
I have
rainfalls I like the I want to [ __ ]
spray my ass oh you like the handle you
got the handle yeah the glass not it's
not a curtain right glass yeah oh here
you go
Toto toilet the day okay the photos are
nice
I'll give it Japanese I believe Japanese
yeah
um family owns a plumbing cotton Etc no
big deal no big and and BD you have a
bath mat or is it just a towel on the
floor I got a [ __ ] relatable bath mat
from Melon really yeah that's kind of
trash how about the diagrammed house you
do it's her previous owner but it's
Ellen's initials I'm kidding I was part
of the deal yeah don't forget about me
uh no it's my initials any heated floors
now that seems like a
uh that seems like a waste la you
wouldn't need that exactly yeah any
fruit trees in your backyard lemon
orange good good question just planted a
an orange okay yeah out front did we're
redoing the front yard redoing the front
yard yep that's what I'm talking about
now when you throw up uh Christmas
decorations in a house like that no no
you put a tree inside no no tree I'm not
I don't robots don't have religion what
is this yeah I don't know Christmas
decorations
no because then you gotta store them and
you got you know what I mean real you
know I know rich people that'll have a
company come and just put them all up
themselves they take them all off
there's no store to go this is the
package I want apply that to my house
break it down when we're done
interesting you might want to look into
that I don't I'm not interested though
and I'm also going to be in Thailand do
you host any dinner parties or anything
no I don't even have a table but
I have a table I left the [ __ ]
furniture at the old place I'm renting
it out
[ __ ] garyvee always be close screwing
them on the rent too no see no nice deal
save the [ __ ] guy a break you know no
gave him a break cause the day he said
hotels
the day he moved in they started
destroying the the land behind the
apartment it's a townhouse so obviously
he was like I want to move and I was
like I'll just I don't want to be an
[ __ ] because I've had really shitty
landlords yeah wait the old house was a
townhouse yeah okay yeah right yeah this
one's single family this one's single
family all right there you go yeah there
you how long were you living in that in
a town 11 years really yeah huh bums me
out a little bit but how come a
townhouse you want more for me yeah a
little bit I expect a little bit more
from you Mr President I mean I try to
keep it low profile I like it it does I
mean he's got a Prius you know Prius
townhouse he's got the reverse osmosis
or whatever he's doing it there's no joy
to me I don't it feels like rubbing it
in people's faces okay that's part of
the fun I know I don't I but people it's
pretty clear people don't want me to do
that do you know what I mean sure people
assume all this [ __ ] about me like pink
shirt stuff and you think you're better
than me so I don't want to be like yeah
if I wore that at Christmas I'd be
getting you think you're better than me
yeah yeah so yeah so I that makes sense
and I also am like Catholic and from
Philly so like and just it's like
so this might be too open-ended but then
what does what does bring you Joy where
is your joy coming in your life I think
that's an underlying issue you guys ever
had [ __ ] before Hey fat ass you ever
get laid
you ever kiss a girl
uh Joy No I can draw like I'm very happy
about making these specials my life's
great I for you the action is the is the
juice you like I like doing the I like
making color I like making it yeah like
I like that's really fun I like the
relationships
uh and I like being
in common I just like it how about
Cologne you rock any cologne
I got uh you know what's the UN
underrated fragrance
two very good guys
very classy very Cowboy
um
the Amber that's that's Amber the scent
Amber is very good so I got an Amber is
that a brand new no it's just a scent
like the scent of Amber the raw the
mineral rock yeah whatever it is we
don't know what it is and what do you do
probably a flower they gave me a roller
okay this guy smells like a dinosaur
[Laughter]
yeah uh so yeah the roller yeah so it's
like an essential oil-ish type thing
you're flossing every day I keep a floss
on me a sticker and a string break it
out let's see really I mean this is on
this this baby's been going a week you
can see somewhere whoa that's crazy get
them out of here Neil Neil come on dude
that's dirty that's crazy it's wear and
tear huh I don't care how many pink
shirts you own that's [ __ ] crazy
yikes uh what about deodorant what are
you using
uh Arm and Hammer you do that's yeah
clear stuff that's good toothpaste
aluminum free toothpaste I'm going
Sensodyne all right yep all right you
brush your teeth in the shower
huh no no you brushed my teeth in the
shower a lot of people do really yeah 50
of the people I would say are you peeing
in there you pee in the shower come on
of course okay all right that's don't
insult me have you ever been to a
Renaissance Fair no
where are you shopping now where you do
the grocery shopping night just got it
delivered I got uh Whole Foods in
walking distance walk up there bring my
own bag that's why La is so cool man
[ __ ] you're in like I got a electric
bike wow I'll ride that thing Suburban
neighborhoods and you're right out right
out of the action yeah it's surprised
honestly I would say it's like King of
Prussia in Pennsylvania
big fan sure for real like whenever the
first time I went to LA I was like oh
this is just like King of Prussia yeah I
worked at the King of Prussia Mall of
course you did fragrance that was the
always that was the rich mall was it
really everything we were Bucks County
was that up shitty Mall yeah I mean
shittier yeah once a year we went to the
King of Prussia mall around Christmas
that was it once a year do a smash and
grab
Mom needed this mom get the purses let's
go is it you know what's interesting
about the modern Smash and grabs they're
all wearing the Nike hoodie yeah yeah
with the tight with the Titan yeah so
yeah I have that hoodie that I had to
stop away we all do yeah yeah and uh and
the other thing I love seeing is
whenever there's a looting situation
someone always comes out and slips yeah
every time the other day a kid ran into
the glass door and knocked himself out
yeah it's all that yeah great that was
all right fantastic anyone in your
family ever own a PT Cruiser
no we had the station wagon though okay
ever been in a helicopter no I'm not
dying of being a helicopter I'm with you
on that hmm flown private before though
yeah never on my own dime though gotcha
even better yeah yeah you know what's
interesting about private jets
it's like a it's a it's like what it's
like people are so broken that we're all
so hooked on like betterment and [ __ ]
sure every all not every time but ninety
percent of the time I've been in a
private jet you land and uh the person
who got the private jet will go that was
the jet I wanted to get there's always a
bigger better jet that they couldn't get
that they wasn't available every like
every time they bring up like oh that's
what we could have been a good private
jet set it down here we're getting I
heard the turbulence is brutal sometimes
too I wouldn't like that
uh I haven't experienced that buddy okay
we bought you can pay enough
yeah hey God yeah cut the weather down
15 grand yeah
the other here's the other downside of
uh uh private jets it's you have to be
social
all right which you don't think about as
like a thing on planes the fun is you
just go in your little thing yeah when
if you're on a private jet it's like a
cocktail party especially if somebody
else paid
I got your nose you're doing this
[ __ ] hey break dance I'm gonna go get
them I'm gonna go downstairs
can't put on your headphones and watch
training yeah and you got a piss and a
jug on a lot of them a lot of them don't
have bathrooms uh I feel like I have a
good story about that really I've never
heard I didn't see it but I heard the
story
before 9 11 there was the at the Aspen
Comedy Festival there was a like a
little puddle jumper it wasn't even a
private jet it was like a 10-seater from
Denver to Aspen that Tracy Morgan was on
and there was no bathroom and Tracy had
to piss so bad he ended up going into
the cockpit and pissing in a bottle in
front of the captain
pull the rudder
um if you're home at the house do you
ever eat in front of the TV you're right
I only eat in front of the table really
and here's a cheap story
so I need furniture for my place uh-huh
a friend of mine brought a friend of
hers to the taping of my Netflix special
blocks and uh I always look to the
monitor for some reason available on
Netflix available on Netflix
um and uh so she works for some Design
Furniture firms okay she got me 50 off
nice I [ __ ] cleaned up there you go
pretty good yeah you do walk in both
worlds yeah cheap and and cheap and
luxury you have name brand luggage
somebody again here's a cheap store
cheap story somebody was smiling tonight
you got the Randy Jackson Collection
this like my the last suitcase I bought
was at Ross Dress for Less it was a
Nautica Nautica uh Nautica after that
you're shopping at Ross Dress for Less
I'm wearing raw socks as we speak my
friend I get they got NBA socks at Ross
right now there you go uh on Lincoln in
L.A Blake Griffin would not approve no I
well but so I told him I went to Ross
and he goes I got I got so many bags ask
me I'm like I'm gonna ask you for a song
you've got a suitcase
they get those guys get new luggage
every season yeah from the team I always
wanted to ask an athlete that because I
think about how I would operate like if
I was a baseball player I'd like would I
want to would I want a brand new uniform
every time but I want a new glove what I
want new cleats this that well they get
because they all their luggage is
handled for them uh-huh so his the he
gave me I think it was the Clippers like
32 it's his says 30. it's all like so
they can ID it for travel that's awesome
yeah uh and
and then somebody bought me uh a roller
bag uh my the guy who ads the
commercials does it roll straight up or
is it the drag I think it's all I think
it was everything yeah do you have a
charger in it phone charger no I had
that one with the I got that one I made
someone buy me the scooter who are you
making you buy stuff going through JFK
airport on that thing I never had the
heart to use it no by the way the things
like [ __ ] half charger yeah that's
what they don't tell you it's a car
battery it weighs like six pounds if
it's half charger yeah uh so so yeah so
I never use that but now I have a uh one
of those like North Face or one of them
okay anybody in your family ever claim
to have seen a UFO no my family's super
square like that okay I've recently in
the last two years
been drinking Ayahuasca and it's the
longest I've gone on a podcast without
bringing it up okay
um and I've recently entered the world
of [ __ ]
wild [ __ ] okay Wild
uh how much you charge for that
Ayahuasca
I don't charge for it's it's uh 700
bucks for a weekend oh yeah all right
okay when you do in Ayahuasca are you
like doing it in like a Shack by a YMCA
because I have a lot of homies who did
that said it wasn't great no I'm doing
it I'm doing like a circle yeah it's
like a journey we call it a journey uh
that's how it's a circle it's like a
more or less like a church oh you're not
just taking it at the house no I know
people that are doing it and putting on
the walls
I was like what are you doing she's like
yeah the guy sent it to me and I would
just drink it and lay in bed I was like
you're [ __ ] with real spiritual so
you go on like spiritual retreats yeah
in essence did one two weeks ago really
what did they give you to vomit into a
Ace Hardware clear plastic bucket that
stack the stack ones compare that to
like the effect like like mushrooms
mushrooms are like a fun party this is
Ayahuasca is not a party and it's
entirely unpredictable I've had
some of the worst experiences of my life
sounds great you gotta do it
uh I've had the it like really helped me
and I've also had I've been thrust into
outer space by myself and the universe
died
oh and my brain was go I'd think what my
brain would go
and I was like oh I'm gonna be [ __ ]
Roger well I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
Pink Floyd like I
and then I did DMT which I talk about in
my new special box
um I I was like not even in the camera
I'm looking at a like the compute I'm
looking at the power outlet
um he's looking at the sun guy
TMT was [ __ ] me up way past
anything I would suggest I
I had the thought not only is this the
worst day of my life this may be the
worst day of any life ever it was this
guy's a real party yeah I was gonna say
a kid likes to party I'm all right
hey did you ever go to space and hate
your life
the whole universe is being murdered
we're shutting it down babies Saturn I
don't even like sharing an elevator
black holes you're crazy done it's we're
shutting we're pulling the lever it's
over but I was an atheist when I started
and now I believe in God so like again
there's like it's there's plus and
minuses that's pretty deep DMT was not
Ayahuasca Ayahuasca is great people
always get confused Ayahuasca is great
it's it's uh natural it's well they're
both natural technically
um but it's way gentler than 5meo bufo
is what it's called the toad the thing
Mike Tyson talking about where I'm like
he's done it like 50 times I did it once
and I was [ __ ] up for five months
uh where I couldn't I'll do drugs kids I
couldn't look at sunsets I couldn't look
at the Apple screen saver on the monitor
Jesus because it was too like I
understood how old Earth just [ __ ] that
like
no human being should
go just like I I would go ahead just get
some weed dude what are you doing we've
done work from it getting a bag on me
right now straighten you out no I like
that that's awesome no it's for dude
it's walking
Wild
yikes I know this guy was a nerd this
dude
or whatever you call I'll do whatever
it's like I did that I used to do acid
and [ __ ] shrimps all the time this
guy's looking inside the Universe I like
it is even happening right now I'm back
no yeah it's [ __ ] wild have you ever
worn pants that zip into shorts
no I don't even know what that is ever
been on a yacht
uh I feel like must the answer must be
yeah okay but
I can't think of when in this Dimension
yeah right any Universe counts well have
you had neparagazi on here not yet not
yet well he's had like uh
he taught like Paul Allen who died but
he like sure Crow
created Microsoft yeah yeah
um and he's the Neil Brand of Microsoft
and uh he but he would have he had like
he had a yacht and it would be like
Jimmy Buffett he would just invite
people on the yacht and then he had Nate
come and do comedy for him oh that's
awesome like he had to go to Thailand to
get on the yacht that's pretty sweet
yeah when was the last time you were on
a boat do you know
uh where have I been
I can't think Hmm I can't think I mean I
know that there's a river in Thailand
um
[Applause]
you get seasick yeah okay yeah all right
which actually doesn't help me with
ayahuasca like it hits me pretty hard oh
yeah you think you'd be yeah yeah do you
have a travel agent
no I don't think they exist anymore do
they they do my mom just booked a trip
to Disney on with a travel agent yeah
you know when you're coming I got the
travel agents got all the information
this is in 1988. you're going to
Disneyland this is 2022. we're going
next Epcot coming soon uh
the travel agent
I had I used to travel agent like three
tours three three four years ago I used
to but I gave them the wrong TSA number
so ever I didn't get TSA app for like 12
airports in a row and I yelled at them
and it was it was miscommunication
you're pre-check now right yeah Global
Entry
come on clear clear some [ __ ] waste
of money okay I might do the clear
because what kind of credit cards you
got Amex platinum and it's free on Amex
Platinum yeah well I saw it but it's
never long enough I saw that it's free
now on Amex yeah but then I went on the
website the website's bunk it doesn't
work I don't know I think if you're in
line they grab you no no I even to apply
oh really for AMEX hmm is that your only
card you're rocking what else you got
you got a Capital One you got to
discover I've got a Visa got a Visa I do
commercials for Chase okay with Kevin
Hart what they give you a card no oh
you're just like I want people to know
I do commercials for Chase
Bank I'm supposed to like I'm like I
feel like if I'm gonna endorse it I'm
sure it's got to be one year send them a
card what are we doing here
oh I think I'm pretty I'm pretty good
well what do you think the verdict is I
don't know it's very rare but I I would
say it's a coin flip let me ask you this
it's a 50 50. it's tough give me just a
couple more cues here to figure this out
um at a restaurant will you when you're
done eating will you stack the plates
and get them ready for the waiter to
take them away or no
only if it helps me
if it gets out you know what I mean yeah
if it's like if it's but I'm not gonna
do it if you're doing the word search or
something like I'm not gonna do it like
I worked I was a I was a waiter for 11
years yeah like what's the splitting of
the check situation
um
you and Nate bargetzi you and Nate
bargetsi go out to go out to lunch I I
we'd probably split really there's a
generally speaking if I feel like I have
more money than the person I'll pay
without question not even thinking about
it like not a question okay
but the thing is that happens like
that's the world Nate lives in also or
like Blake or Rock like somebody that
I'm eating with so we will split because
that it feels it's a gentleman it just
feels nice to like not have to work like
sure but worry about it are you getting
still water or sparkling water tap
you're doing tap yeah appetizers for the
table to share or just for you
but here's the thing one of ten kids
there was not a lot of sharing sure
there was not I'd never seen someone
do the thing where they got I'm going to
the kitchen you need anything until I
was like in my 20s really I just I was
like what do you mean you'll you would
do something yeah yeah I'd wear it to
the kitchen and eat it was ever in the
pot maybe you're a big fatty
hey you're not wrong you made me crazy
but you're not wrong
um cardiologist says the same thing to
me
um he calls you a big fatty everybody
does that's kind of rude I mean I don't
he's not I maybe it's in the in the
medical books now no but I saw him the
other day and he was like I was like
could I drop dead at any moment he's
like yeah you could walk out of here and
you know a lot of things that I'd be
walk out of here you can get hit by a
car or in your case you could be in
Shake Shack and none of your credit card
that's a direct quote for Mike
good time this guy's got a real like
this guy's got a real got a real Essence
I don't know what it is but he's got it
uh yeah so not a lot of uh uh you know
not a lot of sharing not a lot of
sharing no okay but I but I do I have
snapped at people about grabbing my
dessert
every once in a while like if someone
like goes for us like a Elon Gold the
comedian a couple years ago we were
eating and he went and I was like I got
like pissy with him because
dinner together we're out to dinner he
didn't say anything can I try a bite of
that no I would have done the same thing
that's kind of on him yeah that's rude
thank you that's kind of did he have a
dessert as well
I don't know if he did so I know what
your ad wasn't reciprocal yeah I don't
think he did or was it discussed as
ordering like hey I'm gonna get this and
you know you'd like to pronounce it in
any way oh yeah he's wrong that's wrong
yeah I got to give you that thank you
have you ever changed asked to change a
table in a restaurant
um I mean no not because it's well if
it's like there's a there it's a there's
a breeze I have one right now that I'm
thinking about
so you guys stay in hotels pretty often
right yeah so you know the thing when
you that thing that like the foldy thing
I have no you put your luggage on oh
yeah I understand the little stand so
it's in the closet right
the so I open it and put my thing on it
the door won't close
the stand is too wide to be open in the
car to be opened in the closet it's
supposed to be put out in the room it's
not supposed to be opened in the closet
it's the first time hearing anybody try
to keep I don't know if that's true
though really I don't I mean if they you
I ended up putting it on the room but it
takes a lot of space up and there's a
there's enough room in the closet except
for that much of the I think it does
make sense I put in a call to the
manager he wasn't available the manager
not the front desk well whatever yeah
the front desk isn't going to go
anywhere you got to get you gotta speak
yeah
you got to talk Target so what I'm gonna
it's like just shape they're shavable
they're because the I like measure it's
like you can they get a buzz saw and
some black paint
and the whole they changed the
complexion of the whole hotel
you don't expect him to do that after
his visit do you were you like hey get
up here and you know fixing the Sawzall
and whack this up for me I brought a
song I got a song No you don't no I
don't
no but they it's one of these things
where I'm like this is an easy solvent
it's like a big it's a floor very
obvious unforced error that like guys
you know no one can close this I think
you might be the only person trying that
so you thought about it you called down
just to let them know call down shot
over the bow is there a manager
available and I'm not a big like calling
the front desk guy I hate it um but this
felt like
I'm paying a good amount for this room
[ __ ]
like let's Spruce it up a little bit I
think you might just be thinking this
might be the Ayahuasca you've broken the
Paradigm of the thought because I don't
think anybody's ever no one's ever
mentioned that but I would say a CL a
trashy person wouldn't think to do that
a classroom I know but that's the thing
uh see I'm classy for wanting to do it
but I'm trashy for wanting to call the
manager do you know what I mean yeah and
like thinking about Buzz saws and how
much paint it's going to take the last
thing that I got uh
we go to a wedding uh-huh
um
a friend a close friend yeah what do you
what do you what do you put in the
envelope I'm dropping in the envelope
there kind of cash you're looking at I'm
doing a joke about this now
where I got my buddy a gift that was
9.50
they got divorced a year and a half
later I sued him for fraud
really I'm kidding oh Jesus Christ I was
like I don't know right uh
who knows I'm a real Karen who's on home
depot.com
you gonna be there
um got a leaf blower I'm thinking of my
uh my
the last three people my niece just got
married okay example
go ahead
I'll write it down yeah the second time
anybody's done this
Agora did it with how much he spent on
his birthday dinner
that's funny and then we framed it
did you read it of course 52 000. wow we
don't have to read this one though yeah
yeah but we're gonna
so did you leave it's not like it's
anything fifty two thousand then where
did he go I forget
not only gave us the name of it because
it was like yeah it was some restaurant
in Chicago yeah some joint in Chicago he
said there was a group of people there
it was an orange crazy stuff like that
that's good that's good that is such an
odd number though why wasn't it right
you know the Five Below I don't believe
that the fact that you landed on that
number how did you deliver that was that
that wasn't in cash right no no uh yeah
yeah Center check yeah you sent her a
check or brought it to the wedding with
you no I didn't bring it
and you just said you had them send a
check so you were like whoever handles
your yeah yeah your business people yeah
yeah that kind of tipped it over for me
I'm gonna go out first I [ __ ] Neil
you're classy
we're gonna it's gonna be a hung Jory
here I can't I think you're Classic I
can't give it to you he's using [ __ ]
uh bath mats and did you recommend to
the front desk how they should fix the
thing I'm gonna he's got these but he's
got an architecture shave off a little
bit Yeah because I did I know how much
room it's out I mean it's like a [ __ ]
quarter of an inch it's not it's like
nothing and they could fix it
yeah I don't think you're wrong I think
I am yeah no no yeah yeah you
you can walk in both worlds I was
pulling for you though but I'm more I
didn't want to be
uh classy okay you know what I mean down
luggage from NBA players that's trashy
that's really trashy I wonder here's the
trash
yes
I fenced the goddamn watch uh this is a
very trashy story
I was flying business to London
business class and um and it was like I
was in England for a second
um
um and uh
for everyone's d-boarding
and actually I think it was first class
it was somebody paid for it and I you
know what they called on British Airways
upper class which is like [ __ ] you that
makes you wealthy wow anybody can get
bumped up to First Class well the first
one in the little upper class
I got they having a masseuse on the
[ __ ] thing going around nice offering
people massages I'm in there and then I
gotta they give you like a comforter I
got hot fudge on the Comfort on a white
comforter they should be giving you a
like comment I don't know that's their
fault not great and then so this time
second time oh I got a real good trashy
story about staying at the Mandarin
Oriental in Hong Kong keep rolling tape
keep rolling tape
um that's a nice joint yeah yeah oh yeah
uh you know what they do in these nice
hotels they they pump fragrance into the
uh Lobby really yeah real nice I mean uh
and then they said the classes are too
small yeah but yeah you got to talk to
the manager if you want to open it
um trying to find a Lowe's in Hong Kong
forget it
um that's actually where they make all
the tools
um so gone to the source
yeah I know you got it
now like
what am I an idiot uh what am I going to
be one of the most popular comedians in
the country shout out to shame we were
with them last week
uh his special was [ __ ] great
um he's the best the uh
where am I
um sorry man no I had a better I had a
good I had I was telling the dirtbags oh
the upper class upper class all right so
everyone
uh we saw this thing
except Mr Brennan uh uh big fan of your
program mate
little Australian we're all deboarded in
South Africa someone was reading Don
Rickles
autobiography yep called like I'm
kidding or whatever
left it on the seat but everyone
deboarded so I just [ __ ] you stole
the book you stole somebody what they
call him prison cheeked it cheat
huh
yeah yeah garbage dude
the gentleman's rule you want to shut
this thing down once and for all let's
do it Mandarin Oriental Hong Kong six
years ago
uh
uh go to a vegan restaurant in Hong Kong
anyhow uh that night I
you think it's a fart right oh you
really did treat yourself
right we all agree yeah what do you mean
and uh let me write 100 of the time
can't tell uh the lie detector said that
it was not a fart it's not a fart and uh
you are the father straight up shot the
bed the bed yep and
but it was one of these things I was
tired and I was like I could check it
went into the sheet the under sheet and
the mattress
they I just like crumpled them up put
them off to the side
and then uh but then I got a bare
mattress with [ __ ] well
yeah he just put the comforter back over
it necklace you know I don't know how I
got around it anyhow long story short
call the front desk that would [ __ ] in
my bed in this closet's too small
I want a refund to me well you know it's
20 20 hindsight yeah it's easy to say
somebody's Morning Quarterback yeah
somebody snuck into my room and [ __ ] my
underwear this is ridiculous
um yeah it was Chinese
Chinese as they come
uh and
long story short did the same thing the
next night the next night yes learn
nothing did they say anything to you at
the hotel when you checked out what do
you say probably hidden they probably
government what do you say suckers and
stuff yeah no yeah for real like what do
you say there's nothing you could say
but I haven't
I somehow there no reservations are
available
right now around the world holy [ __ ]
yeah you're trash for sure yeah yeah
ladies and gentlemen Mr Neil Brennan
amazing brand new special out on Netflix
called blocks streaming globally you
gotta check it out absolutely amazing
anything else you want the folks that
don't know Neil I'm going on the road
there you go yeah where can we get some
picks neilbrand.com
shows by the way side note Edgar Allan
Poe very terrifying writer a lot less
terrifying when you read it in a
Baltimore accent
Baltimore and Philly accent are right
there they're right right it's at
Mid-Atlantic yeah they're [ __ ] they
got a row home together I would love to
get a home Voldemort yeah this cry won't
shut the [ __ ] up yo I'm sleeping dude
what's up
Neil thank you so much
thank you congratulations on the special
again blocks on Netflix check it the
[ __ ] out pick up some dicks go see Neil
we love you to death Kippy what do you
got for him we're on the road as well
Boston Rhode Island uh those second
shows are selling out so get those grab
tickets gang we love you and we'll see
you next week peace